bagdad 21 août dernier alerte maximum à
l'ambassade de france
ces sommes sont la première ligne de
défense ils n'ont ni visage ni non et
interdictions d'indiquer leur unité
pour la première fois depuis 20 ans un
ministre des affaires étrangères
français sera en irak je suis le seul
autorisé à filmer le déplacement de
bernard kouchner
c'est ici que je fais connaissance avec
jean-françois girault l'ambassadeur de
france ici à gauche
sauf chez vous chez vous monsieur le
ministre oui enfin chez nous visite
exceptionnelle pour un ministre mais la
routine pour les hommes du quai d'orsay
ils n'ont jamais déserté bagdad
tout de même à fort-de-france pâques
[Applaudissements]
sur le toit de l'ambassade alexandre
garcia premier secrétaire a un souci
d'intendance
c'était un spécialiste des situations de
crise mais pour ce genre d'imprévu aucun
manuel du quai d'orsay ne propose deux
solutions
50 degrés ou 55 degrés au soleil et ça
que ce père se cristallise et finissent
par se percer et donc il faut tous les
quasiment tous les échanges et les
refaire alors qu'on les a changés ya pas
longtemps
pour pour 5000 dollars de 5000 $ de sacs
de sable dont conviennent payer est
vraiment cessé couverts par une garantie
mais on ne va pas repayer mais bon c'est
même si le quotidien de cette ambassade
n'a rien d'ordinaire on maintient les
apparences le protocole du quai d'orsay
reste immuable
9h30 pile la sacro-sainte réunion dans
le bureau de l'ambassadeur commencent
tous ici présents sont des spécialistes
dans leur domaine avec des cv un peu
hors normes
frédéric schmitt le consul de l'extrême
récent post la sierra leone et l'algérie
sylvain fourrière le polyglotte il parle
cinq langues expert de l'iran
incontournable ici alexandre garcia le
numéro 2 est aussi officier de sécurité
enfin jean-françois girons le patron la
cinquantaine toute une carrière dans le
monde arabe notamment en syrie il y a 20
ans il était déjà premier conseiller à
bagdad
des raisons de sécurité l'effectif de
l'ambassade a été
limité à l'essentiel
compte tenu de l'attenté de la terreur
pour nos autorités
perception notre connaissance de la
situation
miracle c'est vrai que c'est un peu
c'est un peu juste mais
essayons d'assurer ces quatre hommes
sont les seuls à représenter la france
en irak à chaque réunion revue de presse
locale c'est l'une des missions
assignées à l'ambassade prendre le pouls
de la rue et irakiennes trois fois par
jour lors télégramme informe paris des
derniers développements
a évoqué la possibilité d'un
début de rencontre
ici chacun fait avec les moyens du bord
à la guerre comme à la guerre autrefois
[Musique]
il y avait dans ce bureau le secrétaire
de l'ambassade
le premier conseiller d etat bureaux
vides que nous occupons puisque nous
assurons nous mêmes notre secrétariat
d'ambassadeur tc je te copie y passer
face et des chikhates lui-même et
documents qu'on finance ont fort
heureusement je n'ai pas eu l'occasion
de mettre ce qui des lourds qui
serait revécu en cas de
de bombardements intensifs de
l'ambassade nous utilisons pour nos
déplacements des gilets pare balles qui
sont plus adaptés au costume et la
cravate
je savais en arrivant ici je ne pourrais
pas vous montrer l'une des missions les
plus essentiels que mène la france en
irak le renseignement ce sont les agents
secrets de la dgse qui s'en occupe les
seuls à aller sur le terrain les seuls à
pouvoir rencontrer toutes les factions
du pays
1 km de l'ambassade une voiture piégée
vient d'exploser chaque jour un attentat
de ce type sèment la mort dans la
capitale
l'attak a mis 15 c'est l'obsession des
équipes de sécurité de l'ambassade
contre elle les moyens de défense reste
très rudimentaire
ces murs
oui c'est ce sont des murs anti anti
explosion on appelle ça des à passer à
des tigres dans notre jargon
donc ça fait environ
quatre mètres trop bas 80 de haut sur
deux mètres de large qui a été posé dans
la rue sur la chaussée c'est un vrai
business ici à bagdad
il faut savoir que chaque
chaque morceau
chaque tronçon de 2 m sur 3 m vaut
environ entre 600 et 800 dollars donc
vous imaginez sur sur 30 mètres 40 m ce
que ça peut représenter
si les murs de béton armés protègent
contre des voitures piégées le pire a
été prévu
dans les sous sols se trouve le dernier
recours
alexandre garcia me montre l'ultime
abrite la city room comme il l'appelle
ici une sorte de bunker
donc voilà l'acef tea-room qui est une
pièce de sécurité en cas vraiment
extrêmes limites et de situations
situation critique il faut le dire c'est
blindé les structures sont renforcées on
peut tenir là en cas d'assaut contre
l'ambassade donc il n'ya pas de lumière
attendez je vais allumer je sais pas si
vous allez voir quelque chose
voilà donc une banquette celle ci est
spartiate à une banquette
des réserves d'eau minérale et voilà
alors on s'assoit là on attend que ça
n'attend que ça se passe selon problème
ici évidemment si on est là ça veut dire
la situation et est déjà suffisamment
grave
dans la rue face à l'ambassade les
gardes du corps préparent leur mission
du jour
escortés jean-françois girault dans
bagdad
votre aussi
c'est d'amener de porc
est pour moi toujours la même consigne
ne rien montrer qu'ils puissent révéler
le dispositif de sécurité
ici même les voitures doivent rester
anonyme
en contre nourriture
fillon actuellement ya pas un terreau un
prix qui met qui aurait posé une bombe
de la voiture et puis pratiquer la
voiture ne peut pas le fait qu'on soit
en pleine zone rouge un contrôle
physique des voitures est nécessaire
avant chaque départ de mission c'est la
condition sine qua non d'un autre phase
mécanicien à disposition donc
forcément les réparations ça se fait à
notre niveau et qui arrivent et ses
systèmes d un moteur de question de
laisser les voitures acquises
aujourd'hui l'ambassadeur rendez vous
avec son homologue italien
à chacune de ses sorties un dispositif
bien rodée voiture blindée communication
satellite et brouillard radio bonjour
comment ça va
et si ces mesures échoue ces troupes
d'élite ont pour ordre de se battre
jusqu'au dernier pour protéger le
représentant de la france
le convoi est désormais en pleine ville
le danger peut survenir n'importe où
n'importe quand dans les rues bagdad le
temps de survie d'un occidental lâché
sans protection et de 12 minutes
[Musique]
première cible en irak ces patrouilles
américaines
pour parer à une attaque kamikaze à
chacun de leurs déplacements les convois
us bloquent la circulation et les
soldats américains n'hésitent pas à
tirer à vue si une voiture s'approche
trop près
mais le cauchemar des gardes du corps
français restent les embouteillages
monstres de bagdad
à l'arrêt la voiture de l'ambassadeur
est en danger
quand on rencontre simple il ya un
risque sur
pour lui les irakiens comme pour les
diplôme patron c'est vrai qu'on est
davantage protégés dans une voiture
blindée mais on l'a vu
miliband et allemand ça ne résiste pas
un gros attentat
trop de monde sur ce pont trop
d'activités la voiture doit repartir au
plus vite et le chauffeur se dégage
comme il le peut
là nous sommes sur la rive droite du
tigre le donjon
à gauche la dent la zone vers la droite
de l'ambassade d'iran
ça qui compte envoyé en irak
comme avec
très actif
la fameuse zone verte de bagdad son
accès est des plus strictes
une fois à l'intérieur on découvre une
véritable ville dans la ville de près de
500 hectares ici les américains et leurs
alliés ont créé en miniature l'irak dont
il rêve
c'est quand même une
bull
plus tranquille
sortir le soir des règles du couvre-feu
nous avons dans la zone rouge ne
s'applique pas donc il ya une vie
sociale cades et le commerce les gens et
gens se voient entre eux
la france en zone rouge l'italie en zone
verte à la différence de paris rome a
envoyé des troupes en irak
ces diplomates sont aujourd'hui des
cibles privilégiées alors ils vivent
sous des abris anti mortier
vérifiant comment es tu c'est à toi
même sous les bombes la diplomatie
conserve ses codes et sans savoir vivre
je suis revenu le salon de réception de
l'ambassadeur italien se trouve sous
cette tente de fortune
ça fait plaisir puisque le premier
collègues que je revois
même sous la tente on retrouve
d'élégance italie où il a fait des
dégâts ça peut arranger oui
le poste à bagdad un pet un poste
important mais la méthode sûre très
difficile et je voudrais qu'il y avait
un certain nombre de candidats car je
suis quand j'étais
paumé pour courir ici les diplomates ont
vocation à être nous avons poste de ces
crises et je crois que ça aujourd'hui un
très grand intérêt
en dehors de la violence quotidienne il
ya des institutions irak il ya un
président actif
[Musique]
gouvernement parlement et donc nous
avons des interlocuteurs nous ne sommes
pas au milieu d'une jungle sauvage nous
sommes dans un pays qui est en guerre
avec lui même qui qui cherche sa
réconciliation nationale et la l'italie
la france membre important de l'union
européenne je crois peuple contribuer
très très utilement très très activement
à la solution de cette crise
on me demande de sortir leur tête à tête
durera 1h30
retour à l'ambassade de france
après le stress de la journée des
soirées qui se ressemblent toutes
[Musique]
ces histoires
été dépensés
ça fait du bien d'être à transpirer
la salle a géré
ça le sport et dans les années 70 c'est
à un match d'ores et les gars mais vous
noterez terrain de sport
on a pu y faire un saut vers équipe et
avec les modes de cette salle répond que
par la même occasion la récupérer sa
fille
hier
dans les chambres et confort
rudimentaire mais c'est le seul endroit
où les hommes peuvent pour quelques
heures baisser la garde
c'est plus dur pour la famille qui reste
des fois tout seul dans son quotidien et
et toute la maison avec les enfants le
soir plutôt que tout que nous en fait
dans le travail est baigné dedans du
matin au soir
les gens côtière galatée en france et
c'est vrai que
il voyait que les attentats vous dites à
votre famille vous aller ou pas toujours
jeudi à une seule passe et
je resterai notation
[Musique]
on est faux de ne pas savoir c'est mieux
à l'ambassade de france il y à
l'extraordinaire de la mission il y a
aussi les affaires courantes comme le
service des visas entre 8h et 12h
frederick smith le consul délivre les
précieux sésames 2010 est l'année
dernière mais à bagdad pour remplir les
formalités on est prié de rester dehors
l'ambassade me demandent de protéger
l'identité de ce père de son fils comme
les autres en venant ici ils se mettent
en danger de mort la plupart viennent
chercher des visas d'affaires très rares
sont ceux qui viennent demander le droit
d'asile se perd par exemple les
commerçants il veut aller en france
rencontrer des fournisseurs mais ce
n'est pas le seul but de sa visite
je
il est très honorablement connus service
commercial donc ça ne pose pas de
problème
particulier mais mon problème vient de
son autre fille six femmes
constituaient un
arrière lors du mal à mettre en accord
la profession de pianistes de votre fils
avec le but de l'invitation
et j'ai maintenant 70 ans et j'aimerais
vraiment mes fils m'accompagne dans ce
voyage
regardez c'était en 1979
c'est la dernière fois que j'ai pu
emmener mes enfants en pèlerinage à
lourdes
et de fuir on n'a pas pu y retourner
vous êtes chrétien oui je suis chrétien
catholique
finalement la famille pourra bien faire
son pèlerinage à lourdes
journée importante pour l'ambassadeur
les bonnes nouvelles en irak sont rares
aujourd'hui petite victoire il doit
rouvrir le centre culturel français
toujours cette volonté de maintenir à
tout prix une présence bleu blanc rouge
à bagdad
c'est aujourd'hui le seul centre
culturel occidental en activité
en juin dernier il avait dû fermer trop
de violence trop dangereux pour les
professeurs tous irakien trop de risques
pour leurs étudiants
c'est vous qui êtes allé en france
chaque année l'ambassade fait venir en
france dix élèves irakien les dix
meilleurs en français
cette femme accompagnée ce groupe à
paris
la première fois vous aviez à paris
qu'est ce que vous avez vu par exemple
la tour eiffel
là le musée du loup
ils ont fait tout pour aller au cinéma
et c'était leur première fois parce
qu'ils dans leur vie qu'ils ont mangé
mais
qu'est ce que vous avez vu comme un film
qu'elle filme
alors une
bouffée de liberté
découverte et ils ont vu la vie normale
là on n'a pas mis lamain est là et s'en
défende plus en prend acte et je leur ai
téléphoné alors comment deux années ils
m'ont dit oui madame où on est et où un
humain et ils ont remarqué la différence
quand même
aller
et martial à la rue arrivé alors j aime
et faire
manuellement et la liberté
ces jeunes sont chiites ou sunnites et
le temps d'un voyage à paris tout cela
n'avait plus tant d'importance ils ont
pu oublier la guerre de religion qui
ravage leur pays cette année c'est pas
février ils parlaient ensemble et
sortait et gm ça résume céder encore
il y a
ceux qui croient à l'eva
c'était vraiment un exemple
extraordinaire vous êtes des musulmans
c'est ça
est-ce que vous étés comprendre la route
date
[Applaudissements]
j'ai de la peine de voir la violence
dans ce pays mais on est là pour la main
tendue prête à apporter
notre aide et d'irak et un veau un grand
pays
un beau pays mais aujourd'hui à l'agonie
quand il est revenu à bagdad vingt ans
après son premier séjour jean françois
girault n'a pas reconnu sa ville à
l'époque les rues étaient pleines de vie
aujourd'hui tout est fermé muret
détruits
pour l'ambassadeur tout n'est pas perdu
c'est en tout cas ce qu il veut montrer
il m'emmène à la résidence de france
c'est ici qu'il habiterait en temps de
paix
mais à bagdad on en est encore loin
je
sais c'est un peu dangereux aussi je
devais y rester
plus que quelques minutes avec ses 2000
mètres carrés de propriété entretenu
avec soin la france de montrer à l'irak
qu'elle croit encore en son avenir et
que le passé peut renaître donc cet
espace est un très bel espace de jardin
pour des réceptions je me souviens il ya
20 ans on y faisait de 14 juillet
c'était plat de plasne habitées
donc ces sites vous devriez
or c'est là que devrait vivre
l'ambassadeur c'est un lieu de réception
vous voyez que le ministère a
entièrement restauré entièrement
renouvelé lors du pillage de 2003 tout
avait été pris des fils électriques les
portes les climatisations il restait
absolument plus rien et c'est vrai que
c'est parfois utile d'avoir un bon
pillage vont avoir une restauration
complète de de sa résidence et et le
quai d'orsay voiliers a fait ça très
bien
pour vous avez ici
l'argenterie de la république qui est
prête à
qui est prête à servir avec payer les
places hausse dans tous ses plats cas
sont les assiettes les
voilà et vous avez donc services
traditionnels de porcelaine de la
république avec le monogramme vous avez
découvert christophe le
canton l'ambassadeur c'est quand même
les réceptions mais juste comme ça ça
fait partie de la vie d'un ambassadeur
ça comment là ça fait partie du
métier c'est-à-dire de l'heureux papa
déjeuners dîners réception est à un
moment de travail à un moment de
convivialité un moment de relation
qui est très important dans la vie
diplomatique la littérature en montrer
parfois la caricature mais c'est encore
aujourd'hui
en occident comme en orient des vrais
moments de travail des vrais moments de
contact de compréhension et
d'hospitalité jeunes en manque c'est un
peu grâce à manquer assez assez
cruellement et
espérant que sonic transitoire
[Musique]
d'une explosion oui ça doit être un
départ de de mortier on s'initie elle
assez vite ici à reconnaître les
mortiers des voitures piégées
les tirs
de l'aviation
j'ai des potes
le problème avec ces hélicoptères
américains c'est qu'ils lâchent des
leurs c'est à dire des petits carrés de
métal incandescent alors ça tombe un peu
partout et ça se met ça se fige dans le
fond de la piscine et ça fait
d'horribles traces personne ne se baigne
dans cette eau turquoise mais comme le
reste la piscine a valeur de symbole le
signe que la france a confiance en
l'avenir de l'irak et que la vie peut
reprendre à tout moment
ici comme ailleurs la france à son rang
à tenir
et jean-françois girault en est le
garant
oui c'était le piano de la résidence et
un piano
quart de queue de factures britannique
qui n'a jamais été
excellent
alors lors du pillage de 2003 les gens
ont pris les pieds les pédales en cuivre
le couvercle l'ont jetée dans le jardin
mais c'est une musique trop tard
retour à nos quartiers de chancellerie
avec dans l'oeil toujours cet espoir un
jour pouvoir investir cette maison
yala messieurs
changement de décor l'ambassadeur
retrouve son monde
m
en trois jours ses fruits une série
c'est un peu comme comme dans les
prisons il ya des portes étanches non
pas pour que par peur que nous y
échappions et comme nous protéger et
donc là on entre dans notre ville là
c'est un style un peu loft ça a été fait
avec booth et ses petits mais agréable
voilà
deux représente ma récréation
quotidienne la possibilité de
de s'évader
une demi heure trois quart d'heure
chaque jour
pendant les deux prochaines années de
son séjour à bagdad monsieur
l'ambassadeur continuera de représenter
la france avec son style
son flegme
et sa délicatesse toute diplomatique
[Musique]